- [Instructor] We've talked about the idea
of standard form of a linear
equation in other videos,
and the point of this video
is to clarify something
and resolve some differences
that you might see
in different classes in terms
of what standard form is.
So everyone agrees that standard form
is generally a linear equation
where you have some number times x
plus some number times y
is equal to some number.
So things that are in
standard form would include
things like three x plus
four y is equal to 10,
or two x plus five y
is equal to negative 10.
Everyone would agree that
these are standard form,
and everyone would
agree that the following
are not standard form.
So if I were to write three x is equal to
negative four y plus 10.
Even though these are
equivalent equations,
this is just not in standard form.
Similarly, if I wrote that y is equal to
three times x plus seven, this
is also not in standard form.
Now the place where some
people might disagree
is if you were to see something like
six x plus eight y is equal to 20.
Now why would some folks argue
that this is not standard form?
Well, for some folks, they
would say standard form,
the coefficients on x and
y and our constant term,
so our A, B and C, can't
share any common factors.
Here, six, eight and 20,
they're all divisible by two,
so some folks would argue that
this is not standard form,
and to get it into standard form,
you would divide all of these by two,
and if you did, you would
get this equation here.
Now that's useful because
then you only have
one unique equation, but on Khan Academy,
we do not restrict in that way,
and that is also a very popular
way of thinking about it.
We just want you to think
about it in this form,
Ax plus By is equal to C.
When you do the exercises
on the Khan Academy,
it's not going to be checking
whether these coefficients,
A, B and C are divisible,
have a common factor.
So for Khan Academy purposes,
this is considered standard form,
although don't be surprised
if you encounter some folks
who say, no, we would rather
you remove any common factors.
Now another example
would be something like
negative three x minus four
y is equal to negative 10.
So some folks would argue
that this is not standard form
because they want to see
this first coefficient
right over here, the A,
being greater than zero,
while here it is less than zero.
For our purposes on Khan Academy,
we do consider this standard form,
but I'm just letting you know,
because some folks might not because
this leading coefficient
is not greater than zero.
Now another example that
some people might be
on the edge with would be something like
1.25 x plus 5.50 y
is equal to 10.5.
The reason why some people
might not consider this
standard form is that A,
B and C are not integers.
Some folks would say
to be in standard form,
A, B and C need to be integers,
and you could multiply
both sides of the equation
by some value that will give
you integers for A, B, and C,
but for Khan Academy purposes,
we do consider this to
be in standard form.
We think this is important,
actually not just being
able to have non-integers
as A, B or C, but also being able to have
a negative A, right over there,
because negative three is our A,
and also having coefficients,
having our As, Bs and Cs
having shared factors, we
thing all of that's important
because sometimes the
equation itself has meaning
when you write it that way.
We'll see that when we
do some word problems,
when we actually go into some real life
and we try to construct equations,
and based on the
information in the equation,
it's easier to understand
if you keep it in this form.
So for Khan Academy purposes,
this is all standard form,
but it's good to be aware
in your mathematical lives
that some folks might want
to see the restriction
of no common factor between A, B and C,
that A is greater than zero,
and that A, B and C
need to all be integers,
but Khan Academy does
not hold you to that.